>> Laura: NOW A DEMOCRAT WHO
IS KNOWN DONALD TRUMP FOR MORE
THAN FOUR DECADES EXPOSES WHAT
THE LEFT IS TRYING TO DO WITH
THEIR ABSURD CHARGES OF RACISM
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
ANDY STEIN JOINS US FROM
NEW YORK, WHERE HE USED TO SERVE
AS CITY COUNCIL PRESIDENT.
ANDY, IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
DONALD TRUMP'S A RACIST, THAT'S
ALL WE HEAR FROM THE LEFT.
YOU'VE KNOWN HIM FOR 40 PLUS
YEARS.
TELL US.
>> I'VE KNOWN HIM SINCE 1973.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
IF IT WASN'T SO SERIOUS, IT'D BE
LAUGHABLE.
THIS GUY DOESN'T HAVE AN OUNCE
OF RACISM AND THEN HE JUDGES
PEOPLE ON THE MERITS.
ON THE FIRST NIGHT HE TOOK OVER
MAR-A-LAGO, I THINK IS 85, HE
SAID TO ME, IT'S CRAZY THAT THEY
DON'T ADMIT PLAX IN ANY OF THE
FANCY CLUBS IN PALM BEACH.
I'M GOING TO CHANGE THEM.
I THINK HE SUED THE CITY OF
IN 1980.
I RAISED A LOT OF MEDICAL
SUPPLIES.
WE WERE LIKE TO SEND THEM TO
HAITI, BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE A
PLANE.
I CALLED DONALD TRUMP, HE GAVE
US A PLANE TO TAKE ALL THE
SUPPLIES OVER.
THE LARGEST CONGREGATION IN
QUEENS, THEY NEEDED MONEY FOR
SOME OF THE POOR PARISHIONERS.
I CALLED A LOT OF LIBERAL
FRIENDS IN MANHATTAN.
THEY COULDN'T CARE LESS.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS, I CALLED
DONALD TRUMP IN RIGHT AWAY HE
WROTE A CHECK.
BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT IS THE LOWEST
IT'S BEEN SINCE 1972.
IT'S AT THE LOWEST IT'S BEEN IN
17 YEARS.
THIS GUY SHOULD GET, THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD GET A BIGGER
BLACK VOTE BECAUSE HE'S DONE
MORE FOR THE AFRICAN-AMERICANS
THEY ARE REALLY AFRAID OF.
THEY HAD A PIECE OUT A FEW DAYS
AGO WHERE THEY NOTICED THAT IN
FACT, HIS APPROVAL RATING AMONG
AFRICAN-AMERICANS HAS GONE UP
SINCE THE ELECTION.
OBVIOUSLY HE DIDN'T GET A LOT OF
SUPPORT, HE GOT MORE THAN
MITT ROMNEY DID.
LAST TIME AROUND.
HE IS IMPROVING.
I THINK THAT'S THE DEMOCRATS
WORST NIGHTMARE.
THE STORIES THAT YOU JUST TOLD,
THOSE ANECDOTES THAT YOU'VE
KNOWN HIM FOR SO LONG, WE ALL
HAVE STORIES LIKE THAT.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS THAT THIS
NARRATIVE HAS ALLOWED TO BE
COOKED INTO THE MEDIA AND THE
ATTEMPT TO BRAINWASH THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
JUST AS HIS FRIEND, WE ONLY HAVE
ABOUT 15 SECONDS, FINAL WORD.
>> IT'S THE OLD DEMOCRATIC
PROVIDING REAL JOBS FOR REAL